الانفلونزا المنتشره حاليا اخطر من كورونا
ولا يبدو العالم قلقا بالقدر ذاته خلال
الايام الاسابيع الماضيه بالتاكيد لاحظ
الكثير منا انتشار حالات انفلونزا تشتاحوا
المدارس تصيب كبار السن ولا ينجو الشباب
من الاصابه بها ايضا اعراض هذه الانفلونزا
تظهر بشكل حمى وسعال مع صعوبه في التنفس
وغيرها من اعراض البرد وهنا منظمه الصحه
قدمت لنا خبرين الاول جيد والاخر سنعتبره
تحضيره لنبدا بالخبر الجيد جود نيوز وهو
ان نهايه كورفت نايتين باتت قريبه اما
الخبر الاخر فهو ان هناك انتشارا هائل هذا
العام لفايروس خطير قد يتسبب باصابات
كثيره هذا الشتاء حول العالم يعرف باسم
الفايروس التنفس المخلوي او ار اس بي قبل
الحوار مع ضيفنا المختص نتعرف على هذا
الفيروس اكثر في هذا الشرح معي كلام الناس
الفايروس المخلوي التنفسي ار اس بي يعتبر
شديد العدوى وغالبا ما يصيب التهابات
شديده في الجهاز التنفسي عند الاطفال
والبالغين بحسب خبراء الصحه ينتشر في
الفتره الممتده بين نوفمبر الى مارس حيث
تعد الموسم الفيروسي التقليدي وتدوم
الاصابه به لمده اسبوعين وفي بعض الحالات
الحاده يضطر المصاب الى الذهاب الى
المستشفى في بريطانيا تشير الارقام الى ان
هذا الفيروس هو السبب الرئيسي لدخول
الاطفال الى المستشفيات وفي مصر اظهرت
نتائج الاختبارات ان ثلاثه 73% من الاطفال
مصابون بالفيروس التنفسي المخلوي كمان
قناه دراسه الهولنديه الجديده من تاكيد ان
هذا الفايروس هو السبب الرئيسي الثاني
بالوفاه خلال السنه الاولى من حياه الطفل
بعد الملاريا وتصل الى ما بين 100 الى
200,000 طفل كل عام وحتى الان لا يوجد
علاج محدد للفيروس المخلويه التنفسي عند
الاطفال الاصحاء وبالتالي فان المساعده في
الحالات الحاده تكون بالذهاب الى
المستشفيات المزدحمه
[موسيقى]
تذهب معكم الى عمان مستشار في العلاج
الدواء السريري للامراض المعديه دكتور
ضرار بلعاوي دكتور ضرار ضرار يسعد هالصباح
اولا يعني بلشت كورونا تختفي وبطلنا نشوفك
على الهوا مباشره احنا بنتمنى لكرونا تروح
بس نضل نشوفك بالاول
صباح الخير يا ستي لك وللمشاهدين الكرام
صحيح يعني هو الناس ارتاحت شويه منا ايه
وان شاء الله يكون الداعي خير ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله اكيد طيب اليوم على ما بنحكي
عن ار اس في هل هذا الفيروس اللي كنتم
انتم كطباء وكعلماء مختصين تحذرونا منه
بفتره كورونا انه الاتي اعظم من الفيروسات
نعم ستي صحيح اذا بتتذكروا احنا عبر
قناتكم المهنيه حكينا انه احنا ما نخشاه
انه بعد يعني الانتهاء من جائحه كورونا
ولا اقول الانتهاء منكم لانه كوروناس ما
زال موجوده وسيبقى معنا احنا الخوف انه
بتعرفي بعد يعني سنتين الى ثلاث سنوات من
هذا الحجر من هذا العزل من الكمامات
الابتعاد الجسدي جسمنا لم يتعرض لهذه
الفايروسات ومن اهمها اللي هو الانفلونزا
التنفس المخلوي
الرزفي ولهذا احنا كنا نتوقع انه نعم
حتتصير في عندنا اصابات من انفلونزا
والارز في اكثر من المعتاد عليها وبدي انا
اوضح اضاءه للمشاهدين الكرام عشان ما
نخوفهم لا هو مش انه والله الفارس توحش
يعني الاعراس في ولا الانفلونزا تغيرت
وصار في عندنا فايروسات ممكن تؤدي الى
وباء لا ليس هذا القصد القصد انه اجسامنا
لم تتعرض للانفلونزا والارز في السنوات
الثلاثه السابقه وبالتالي ممكن تكون
الاعراض شوي اصعب فقط لا غير نعم دكتور
ضرار اللافت انه كورونا كان يصيب الكبار
قبل الصغار يعني كانوا شوي الصغار محصنين
اليوم لما بنحكي عن ار اس في هو يصيب
الصغار والاطفال بالدرجه الاولى كيف نفهم
ذلك
60 الارث في ليس فايروس جديده عشان بس
نعرف في الارض احنا بنعرف ومن همم يعني
مئات سنوات الارز في 60 هو فايروس يصيب
يعني بعد سنتين من عمر الطفل يكون اغلب
الاطفال قد اصيبوا في اصلا واصابته بتكون
خفيفه الى متوسطه الا الا عند الاطفال
اللي بيكون في عندهم امراض في القلب امراض
في الجهاز التنفسي او او اطفال الخداج
اللي اعمارهم يعني ولد وما قبل الاوانهم
اللي ممكن يتعرضوا الى يعني مضاعفات شديده
وممكن يصيب ايضا كبار السن اكثر شيء يعني
حتى اللي عندهم يعني برده امراض مزمنه
ممكن اما العادي انه هذا الارز فيه يسبب
لنا اعراض زكاميه بسيطه تذهب من اسبوع الى
اسبوعين وما في خوف ابدا منه نعم
شو وضع الفلوفكسين بهاي الحاله هل انتم
بتنصحوا انه كل الناس واغلبيه الناس تاخذ
الفلوباكسين بهاي الحاله
قطعا نعم يا سيدتي احنا الان يعني دائما
بقول احنا وصلنا الان في مرحله مسميات
تربل دمك يعني في عندنا ثلاث فيروسات هلا
بتطلعوا علينا عندنا الكوبيد الكورونا في
عندنا الارز في الفارس المخلوي وفي عندنا
الانفلونزا هلا كورونا عنا منه لقاح فانا
بانصح خصوصا الفئات ذات الاخطار العالي
انها تخرج جرعه الان وبالنسبه للانفلونزا
نعم عندنا لقاح فانا بارجو من الجميع انه
ياخذوا جرعه الثلاثي او الرباعي ما بيفرق
الارز في الى الان ما في عندنا لقاح لكن
ان شاء الله خلال ست اشهر الى سنه هناك
وعود من شركات مثل فايزر ومودرن انه
يخرجوا بلقاح لا القارس في لا بل ان تكون
حقنه اللقاح ثلاثيه يعني فيها انفلونزا
وفيها كرونه وفيها الارز في ان شاء الله
نعم وان شاء الله احنا بنشكرك جزيل الش من
عمان مستشار في علاج الدواء السرير
للامراض المعديه يا دكتور ضرار بن عوي